[Music]
DLO thing
[Music]
she shook her booty
and she literally lit up the stage
during her epic performance at the 2018
MTV Video Music Awards where she was
honored with the prestigious Michael
Jackson video Vanguard Award the 49 year
old singer kicked things off floating
above the stage in a billowing gown
and she went on to play a medley of her
careers hits over the past 20 years
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
at one point she was joined by TJ Kalin
and Joe rule who helped her sing ain't
it funny and I'm real
move reminiscent of our last VMA
performance in 2001 JLo glowed while
accepting her big award paying tribute
to her twins max an Emmy there's so much
more to do and I know in my heart that
the future is even brighter than
anything I could have accomplished up to
now because you and she of course
thanked her beau Alex Rodriguez you are
like my twin soul
we're like mirror images of each other
you know my life is is sweeter and
better with you in it because you make
me realize that every day the sky is not
the limit
[Music]